i'm joined now by my peers back
socialist author grace blakely the times
political sketch writer quentin let's
sky news australia host aaron well
welcome all of you what a powerful pack
it is tonight uh quentin great to see
you you're as deep as ruth kennedy yeah
she had a very deep voice quentin let me
ask you with this this hot potato
question what is a woman
my wife right she's a woman but uh what
is a woman i don't know it's the
opposite of a man how about that have we
got to a place where this is even
something that gets debated and people
are horrified about even answering it
well it's a sort of linguistic terrorism
uh that's been going on and uh absurd
and it means absolutely nothing in the
real world of politics
as in electoral politics it means has
absolutely no impact at all so it's just
lunacy that the elite is getting itself
into a lather about i mean where it gets
i think sort of more dangerous we've
talked about the sport issue which i
think is just unfair but there's also
grace uh that sanji javid has come out
today and said he wants nhs website to
start using
woman as a term again and the reason for
that is they eliminated the word woman
to try and be more inclusive and it
turned out that they were actually
making them more dangerous for people to
actually get the health treatment they
need presumably they changed it to avoid
confusion for people who do identify as
women
so
the point being if you remove all female
specific terminology actually a lot of
people who are at the lower
socioeconomic range in this country who
are already maybe confused who don't
speak english as a natural language
whatever it may be they have even more
reason not to understand what they
should be doing to save their lives so
this does have consequences language
eradication like i think calling it
linguistic terrorism is a bit much i
think the vast majority of people
actually including lots of my trans
friends actually who've spoken about
this are just like
who cares at this point about what we're
calling x or y zed or like what we're
labeling things or you know all these
questions around who does what in sports
actually the biggest issues facing trans
people are the biggest issues facing a
lot of other people which are they can't
afford to heat their homes they can't
afford to you know get good jobs that
provide them with good pay and good
security they also you know suffer with
a number of other issues like they're
more likely to get attacked and abused
and all that other stuff in the street
so probably focus on that rather than
all of this stuff about so when you get
asked what is a woman what's your answer
i would say a cisgender woman is someone
who's born with female sex organs at
birth and continues to identify as a
woman and a transgender woman is someone
who's born with male sex organs at birth
and then identifies as a woman later in
life i mean that to me seems actually a
very easy way of solving the problem you
call trans women trans women i know
that's fine i think most people would be
very happy
i know don't really care i think you're
right i think it's being whipped up by
as always extremists on these debates
you make it very difficult um i want to
come to another hot potato erin modern
because you and i are going to fall out
of this
because you've sent this this animal
over to wimbledon here nick curious
who has got plenty of form for behaving
like a beast and has excelled himself at
wimbledon already i want to play a
little clip of him in action where he
basically abused everybody yesterday
spectators who spend money to come watch
us
they should be removed
has one person today come to see her
speak no
like i know you got fans
but she got none
you know a couple lucky shots here or
there but
he put himself in a position to win
he's basically a pig he's eating his
food as he talks to the media he abuses
a female lines woman abuses an elderly
lines man he abuses the crowd he spits
at one of them i mean the man's out of
control can you put up any defense for
this antipathy a monster
[Laughter]
here's this there's plenty of
australians who think he's an absolute
tool as well i'll give you the nod and
i've been one of his most
vocal critics for a very long time but i
tell you what the spitting even towards
someone at their direction is appalling
the abuse of anyone in their workplace
is appalling the hypocrisy that he
displays is completely appalling he
replied to someone on social media
overnight that had taken him to task
over this and said oh but i would never
go into your workplace and abuse you
does he think the linesmen are
volunteers that's their workplace he's
abusing them but what i will say
is it gives you brits something to
complain about and you love that you
love having someone from somewhere else
to complain about and to get angry about
well you know what we complained about
i actually secretly love this well i do
like a complaint but i have to say think
about wimbledon it has this rarefied
atmosphere it's the elite of our society
people dress up they're polite to each
other they eat strawberries they drink
pims they have a nice time and then you
get this guy coming along wrecking it
all for everybody and that unlike john
mcenroe at least was good enough to win
he's not even that
good he goes writing checks
look look you're right and you kind of
need to earn the right to be a complete
flog on the court don't you make a great
point that if he was actually winning
grand slams and winning titles it might
be slightly easier to stomach but he's
entertaining you know he won the doubles
here in australia with his mate the
special case they called them it puts
buns on seats and people watch it's like
a car crash it's like you look at your
ads love him or loathe him you can't
look away and that's exactly what nick
curios is well i'm afraid despite your
spiritual defense
erin despite your spirit of defense he
is winning my douche of the door should
i say deuce
um we'll come back to you in a moment
aaron i'm going to talk to the panel
battle memorial series now uh the
breakup of the united kingdom grace i'm
very sad about what i feel is happening
i feel like it's almost inevitable
triggered by brexit that this sort of
sense of independence now is contagious
scotland is probably gonna in my
lifetime break away i think ireland uh
we're going to have united ireland that
northern ireland will break away from
the union and there won't be a united
kingdom
how do you feel about it i feel that you
know all of these questions are best
settled by the people themselves and i'm
a great advocate of the democratic
process you know i voted remain for
example but when it was clear that the
country got behind leave i was then like
right okay well we need to get behind
that we need to make sure that we
deliver on because you can't rescind a
vote like that uh if it's been you know
subject to democratic approval i think
you know the same thing for the people
of scotland if that is what they really
want if they continue to really push for
independence and if nikola surgeon does
get that referendum which she could do
at the next election if it is as looks
likely
not um a conservative government um and
you know labor has to go into a
coalition with the smp um but again you
know this is a question for the scottish
people the fact that they continue to
vote snp in such high numbers is i think
just as much about a rejection of the
two other main parties
as it is about independence so you know
we'll see what happens if when they see
i mean it always makes me chuckle when i
see the very people who are most enraged
by scotland breaking off on their own
are the brexiteers who i think that's
true i think it is true most brexiteers
are pretty incensed that scotland would
have the audacity to do this and yet the
brexiteers had the same argument we want
to go off on our own we want to do our
own thing i don't think that's true at
all i think you're drifting a bit there
because
my suspicion
i've no
proof for this but my suspicion is that
a lot of english people would think if
the scots want to become independent
well let them go because uh the
economics of the matter mean that the
english and the welsh and northern
ireland should be better off without the
scots um and i think that's the brutal
uh
there's a reality of what a lot of the
english
uh now would say i think that grace
makes a very good point about uh
democracy if the scots want to go they
should be allowed to go and the worst
thing possible would be to somehow sort
of kettle drum them into
a uk that they didn't want to be part of
but i'm not convinced that uh the givens
are all there and i suspect that the the
scots might decide the scottish voters
might decide as they did last time
to they might they might or they might
i've got a bad feeling that they won't
why'd you say bad feeling though because
i like you know i like the idea of
united kingdom i like the idea of us
being part of europe personally
but i mean i've seen nobody i've seen no
benefit so far notwithstanding we've
been hit by other events i have not seen
a single benefit of brexit so far i've
seen the complete opposition oh well
that's complete nonsense because there
is automatically the democratic
accountability benefit and if we had not
come out of the european union after
that referendum i think it would have
been a scam one benefit i would give it
actually is i think the vaccine program
the way that we were able to opt out of
the european collective but i think i'm
making quite an important point here if
the uh referendum result had somehow
been overturned i think we'd have looked
stupid i mean that's not really a case
for saying that the way that the brexit
process has been handled has been good
sure there was a mandate to respect that
democratic decision
but that's correct brexit was always
this you know big thing was presented to
the country as a done deal just say vote
for this thing and you'll get given it
it was never that was always a process
and the way it's been managed has been
really bad by the conservatives the same
thing might happen with scottish
independence but you know if the scots
vote for independence they should be
given well i i ultimately start i
believe like grace in democracy let's
talk about boris johnson saying that if
putin was female this wouldn't have
happened before god
i just despair it's like when um i think
it was arianna huffington after the
financial crisis said if it had been
lehman sisters this never would have
happened honestly i just find the kind
of
like the liberal feminism and i use
liberal in the british sense of the term
not in the american sense of the term
where there's no attempt to kind of look
at power relations you know essentially
look at politics and economics and the
systems that underpin all our lives it's
just like women are over here and men
are over here and often actually it is
very dichotomized as well you're like
yeah women are great because they're
nice and sweet and caring and they look
after kids and men are in the boardroom
and they're violent and competitive it's
all awesome
there have been some despicable female
leaders
catherine the great great uh russian
leader actually
seized um
so the the some of these areas now being
fought over uh for russia in the uh when
it was it was early early eighteen
hundreds but uh or perhaps a hundred
years out however uh i would say this
that um i think a little bit of baiting
of putin is no bad thing no and also
when you look at putin there's a
peculiar figure i mean you sort of
imagine him where he a greyhound he'd
have very very tight backside uh uh
back area but you know there's a sort of
slight sort of scent you can imagine
from putin if you were up close to him
the smell of links after [ __ ]
there'd be a slight i want to bring in
eric
not nocturnal vastly
that women make sort of more peaceful
leaders and none of these wars would be
happening i mean did you buy into that
no not at all and a quick google of the
world's most evil women and i'm not
trying to beat up the british here but a
lot of them come from your side of the
neck of the world it's bloody mary i
think leading the way there but no look
if he'd said that uh if putin had not
been a narcissistic psychopath then i'd
probably agree with that more if he'd
said maybe if america hadn't weakened so
significantly under the biden
administration uh putin may not have
invaded ukraine i believe in that more i
i i agree i think you know what i think
we've actually reached a point of
consensus on this panel which is highly
unusual thank you grace thank you
quentin thank you to erin
i appreciate it every week
i wanna win just with a few words about
dame deborah james aka bowel babe she
was an extraordinary woman who died aged
40 last night to battling bowel cancer
for five years raising millions of
donations for research above all her
legacy will be raising the spirits of
millions of cancer sufferers around the
world with her witty sharp and searingly
honest commentaries on living and
ultimately dying with a disease she was
a great lady and she did a great job for
so many people and she will be deeply
missed by this country thank you dame
deborah